we talked last week about a poll that
showed
that 64 of current republicans
are willing to leave the republican
party if donald trump were to start
a third party and uh this
reinforced the sort of soft nature of
much of the support of the republican
party
as well as the cachet that donald trump
at least now
as we approach one month since he's been
out of office that for at least now
donald trump still has on the republican
party
uh but that is all hypothetical those
are people who
would be willing to leave the republican
party what about people that
are leaving and not because trump
starred in another party but just
because they're leaving
there's a very interesting series of
studies many of them out of california
some out
of florida as well which show that there
are already
thousands and thousands of voters in
some counties that are leaving the
republican party
um and what they where they are going
remains a question and we're going to
talk about that in a moment
um but this seems to be a reaction to
uh the defeat of donald trump combined
with
two months of lies about the election
supposedly having been
stolen from him and of voting experts at
the university of florida
say that there are thousands and
thousands of republicans that are no
longer traditional republicans that are
no longer
registered as republicans anymore
and that while there are often changes
to party registrations
all the time and in particular after
elections that the number of republicans
leaving the party are significantly
greater
in number than the number of democrats
that are changing their registrations
they look at san diego county and
california as well as some other uh
parts of
of the country and um it appears as
though
the january 6th trump riot was sort of
like the straw that broke the camel's
back it's unclear that
it alone is the explanation for why so
many republicans are abandoning their
party but rather
the sort of culmination to months and
really years
of a complete joke of a republican party
with donald trump
at the helm at its head and it is
believed indeed that
the abandonment of the republican party
by these folks is a sort of rejection of
trumpism more than it is of what the
republican party used to be
these folks who are leaving widely
believed to still be in line
with whatever values or ideologies
brought them in in the first place
whether it was ronald reagan 40 years
ago or whether it was
someone like uh either of the george
bush's
um or more the newt gingrich style early
90s politics that attracted people to
the republican party or folks like john
mccain and mitt romney more recent
republican nominees
whatever it was that brought them in
they still they're not leftists
they're not leaving because they're
leftists but they're leaving as a
rejection of trumpism is what it seems
to be now there's a really important and
obvious question to ask if we want to
figure out
what is or is there an electoral impact
to this which is
okay if you leave the republican party
are you still voting for republicans
unless we have reason to believe
otherwise they probably
are you can leave the republican party
and be an independent and still vote
just for republicans
and i can't imagine that many of these
folks are looking to vote for democrats
at the state and local level maybe some
would stay home which would still be
help to the democratic party and sadly
i believe most of these folks will be
very quick to return if indeed what
they're doing is rejecting trumpism by
leaving
as soon as the media focus gets back to
black lives matter is terrible
and joe biden's allowing immigrants into
the country and oh the debt and the
deficit and all of that
tried and true stuff that we predicted
republicans would go back to after trump
and that we're already seeing them go
back to after trump
i believe many will return to the party
and importantly i don't think many of
these folks
will opt to vote for democrats rather
than
whatever republicans they can vote for
in 2022
and in 2024 assuming donald trump is not
the nominee at that point in time
so you know you know independents who
used to be republicans that still vote
for republicans
not super interesting and it's important
to know
as a general political concept when we
talk about independence
there are some folks who uh like to
frame themselves as these enlightened
centrists that are not loyal to either
party
and sometimes they vote for republicans
or for democrats or green party or
whatever
the vast majority of independents vote
overwhelmingly for one party or the
other
and they are essentially as partisan
as most democrats or republicans they
just aren't officially affiliated with
any party
and let's not overstate the importance
of party registration alone now that
being said
uh if a lot of republicans are
abandoning the party
if some of them are saying for the time
being i'm not going to be donating
these are things that could make a
difference the question then becomes
will democrats take advantage of it and
that
certainly remains to be seen